[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
today i'm talking to
uh actress model tick-tock face mask
maker extraordinaire sydney morgan she
is just so lovely we talk about how she
got into tick-tock into tick-tock uh how
a coffee mask uh making
tick-tock kind of blew up and has
launched her into an influencer career
what that's like also how uh being 16
years old in high school and having
ulcerative colitis really impacted her
entire uh human existence she had her
entire colon removed it's a pretty wild
story we also talk about crystals she's
very into crystals and all the
properties with them and i am also an
amateur crystal observer so we talk all
about it and she just moved to los
angeles her thoughts on that her
thoughts on the entire world of tick
tock i get a lot of uh advice that i
gleaned as an old millennial trying to
figure it out for myself but overall
sydney is absolutely lovely and very
hilarious so please enjoy this episode
not too deep with sydney morgan
[Music]
all right sydney i'm so excited to talk
to you i feel like i'm going to learn
so much
uh but first of all
i had to hear from you
how do you
describe
what you do
that's such an interesting question
considering it changes every couple
weeks because i'm like you know what i'm
just i'm going to be an actor now yeah
just keep changing
so uh i usually say that i'm a content
creator on social media and i'm also an
actress and model
cool makeup artist clearly yeah okay
that's the thing is that you have these
hybrids uh about you which is very
interesting and i want to hear i know a
little bit about how the tick tock
journey started but i'm curious from
your perspective how did this all come
about
yeah so i've always been very artistic
and creative i always say i've been
drawing and painting ever since i could
pick up a pencil and so
when i was in high school i was in the
art club and i would volunteer in my
community to do face painting on kids at
certain events and cute all the kids
would like come to my line because
they're like oh sydney does it so good
so i was like i was like wait a second
i'm kind of good at this
and then uh fast forward to the pandemic
um
i had a lot of free time and i started
you know face painting on myself and i
had a very small instagram account at
the time just to post all my artwork and
my makeup looks on just for like friends
and family and then tick tock was this
new app and i had seen other makeup
artists using it and i was like i might
as well share it there as well so it
just started as this
another platform to share my art on and
then it just had a great response and i
just never stopped yeah that's kind of
how tick-tock came to me
i mean so you were already looking at
tick-tock and watching like
beauty gurus and whatever up there and
we're like oh i see this spicy spy i can
do this right no i've always been very
into like the beauty community on
youtube so i i was kind of growing up
watching these youtubers online and i
always watched and i was like yeah i'm
gonna do that
that'd be cool i never thought i
actually would but i was like yeah when
when i'm a youtuber i'm going to go buy
sydney morgan i mean that sounds good
it's like yeah a lot of little kids
dream about like if they're gonna take
someone's last name when they get
married and you're like this is gonna be
my handle when i get my social media
going i was like i was like james
charles that's his middle name i should
use my middle name
now
you blew up a little bit with this video
of you making a coffee face mask correct
uh-huh that was kind of further down the
line but yes okay so
walk me through that this is just an
idea you had or something that inspired
you
and without knowing
it happened and then without knowing
millions of people were like this is
content i enjoy
that still baffles me because it's like
it's not the makeup look that i spent 10
hours on the close-up it's it's me
failing to create a
face mask made out of coffee and so i
had seen these little
face mask maker machines online and i've
seen people using them to make like
little aesthetic like spa day face mask
and i'm like oh slay so i'm gonna buy
that but i'm not gonna do it like that
i'm gonna use crazy things yeah so i
think the first one i did was orbeez i
was going through an orbeez phase i was
working them into content i i don't know
why my followers loved it
not sponsored at all but just a genuine
face
um i just started using random things
and then on the videos there would be
more comments saying use this use this
use this and so i saw when it was like
used coffee and i was like okay i have
coffee i can do that yeah and i guess
the coffee beans
mixed with whatever's supposed to make
it solidify had not a great reaction
and it just went all over me
and i was like i was like let's just
post it anyways that's funny yeah yeah i
could not tell you why it blew up but it
did i know that's the mystery of all
social media is trying to figure out the
why things hit with people and it is
very difficult but from there you've
been making obviously a lot of other
content that is beauty related and a lot
of other face masks i'm curious
uh which ones have worked the best or
which ones have been the absolute worst
have there been any that haven't even
seen the light of tick tock
as far as face masks are though yeah
well or just general videos
so people ask me all the time um like do
you ever hate your makeup books and like
not post them
i mean with art i feel like it's always
like
you can just add on to it or make it
work so
i'm never like oh i'm four hours into a
look and i realize i hate it and i'm
going to throw it away
how can i fix it so pretty much every
makeup look i've started i've posted
obviously there's some that i like more
than others yeah and uh with the face
masks i think my favorite one that i've
ever done was a glitter face mask so i
just used like chunky glitter and it did
solidify and it looked i was feeling my
unicorn fantasy it was just iconic and i
think that was my favorite one
now how do your pores feel
about all of these products that you're
using in these face masks
i mean i mean i don't think they're that
mad at me because as soon as i do it i'm
like okay we got a good take run to the
bathroom scrub my face off and it seems
okay okay okay i didn't know if there
was any yeah the journey after the
process of
describing the face yes
i'm also curious because i'm still of
the millennial generation that's
figuring out tick-tock i'm curious how
how do you describe tick-tock like let's
say an alien came down and had no
concept of this like how would you
explain it to that thing
i guess it's an app where you can post
short videos on
and
i don't even know like
well okay then let me ask
what do you
in using it and having success are there
certain
pieces of advice that you would give
people
uh
to use it like do you see people making
tick tock mistakes or
making kind of like faux pas so you're
like oh they should fix this or that
yeah 100
um
one thing that i think is super
important to tick-tock and getting on
the algorithm and getting that viral
video is consistency
so obviously the more you're posting the
higher the chance that one of them is
going to blow up and get pushed out so
consistency is super important and also
like being authentic and original and
creative because at the end of the day
you want to think what is going to make
people come to my page versus all the
millions of other makeup artists on tick
tock why why am i different why do
people want to come follow me
so i i'm one that i always kind of
create my own makeup looks i don't do a
lot of recreations of other things that
i've seen before
and i think the third reason is just
make sure
you're doing it for the right reasons
because i hear a lot of people going in
like i want to be tick-tock famous yeah
right yeah and so that's not a good
sustainable reason and
we're fulfilling
100 so i think part of my success came
from the fact that i did have this
passion for art and creativity and
makeup and whether i was getting 10
views or 10 million views i would still
be doing it and i'd still be posting it
because i genuinely enjoy doing it
that's great that's very cool um i do
think that you have a really great
perspective and i'm curious if it comes
from
uh that you were diagnosed with all all
sort of colitis am i saying that
correctly yes ulcerative colitis you can
just say uc you see now talk to me about
this this was when you were in high
school
yeah so i was diagnosed with ulcerative
colitis in august of 2018 so that would
put me at 16 years old i was going into
my junior year of high school
and it was it was really scary and
overwhelming at the time because as far
as i knew i go to the doctor they tell
you what's wrong and they give you
medicine and you're fixed
so for me to go in there and then be
like um this is never gonna go away
there's no cure this is something that
you could be potentially dealing with
for your whole life that was just the
craziest thing to me and i had never
even heard of it before i was diagnosed
let alone know anything about it and
that is why i'm so
vocal about it on my platforms because i
kind of
i want people to know so it's not so
scary and there's not this like stigma
around it or uncertainty
yeah i think a lot of especially women
deal with
the
misdiagnoses or like undiagnosed kind of
especially stomach pain especially
because i i you know i've heard the
doctors will attribute it to like a
period pain and not really take it
seriously and not really understand the
depths of it i'm curious like for you
well i mean i assume that it was like
such a physical ailment that like you
had to keep going to the doctor but did
you ever feel like you weren't taken
seriously or feel like you had to like
over explain yourself
yeah so before i even told my parents i
think i was having symptoms for about
four months yeah and i just kept telling
myself oh it's just like a stomach bug
it's this it's that it'll go away and
then so eventually when it didn't it got
so like
limiting that i i had to tell someone
but obviously the symptoms are
embarrassing so it's not something that
people like to talk about so i remember
going to my
uh doctor and they were like oh we don't
really know
and then eventually got to the point
where i had to go to the emergency room
and i was in there for two days and then
i think they were like oh we can do a
scope on you in two months
i
i'm gonna sit in this body with this
pain for another two months
right so then send me home from the er i
ended up back there the next day i was
inpatient for probably two or three
weeks doing tests getting imaging scopes
every test they have and then
ultimately colitis is worked out
so what happened after that
um i spent majority of my first year
after diagnosis burning through all the
different oral medications i was getting
infusions
wow and every medicine possible and it
was like every time there was a new one
i would get my hopes up like this one is
going to get me in remission yeah
ultimately would fail and move on to the
next one and then we got to the end of
the line and my doctor had to sit down
and talk to me like listen this is the
last one
if it fails there's not much else we can
do for you you're going to have to get
surgery to have your entire colon which
is your large intestine removed wow so
she had me meet with a surgeon in
advance just in case we had to have that
next step and then
uh they took me back in to do another
scope to look at it and it was so
damaged at the time that they were
scared that it would just tear while
they were doing the scope
so then i had to get emergency surgery
to remove my colon and that was in
october of 2019. wow
now
i mean that's
wild and i'm sure you're still
processing how wild of an experience
that was do you have any
sort of thoughts or advice to other
young people that might be like
struggling with a medical situation that
hasn't been completely figured out yet
it's so hard i think it's just super
important to remember that uh this pain
is not going to last forever
eventually it will get figured out and
you're going to be okay again it's just
it's it doesn't feel like that at the
time and i know that more than anyone
it's just like and i kept asking like oh
why me why is this happening to me and
my life sucks
but then you just have to get over it
and deal with it like and just take it
one day at a time just stay positive and
remember that it is going to get better
yeah
yeah
that's great um
now i want to ask you about crystals
so
this seems to be something that i've
gleaned from your videos that you are an
enthusiast of in some respects
some might say obsessed with some may
say
okay talk to me about this how did you
get into crystals how obsessed are you
etc etc
my friends would say obsessed just the
right word i think
how did i even get into crystals i just
love shiny things yeah yeah yeah okay
iridescent is my favorite color
okay i'm just attracted to shiny things
and
i don't even know how i got my first
crystal i just was seeing all these cute
little gurus online with their crystals
and i'm like oh my god i want to be that
and so i think i got like one or two
small ones and a company sent me a few
too to help me start my collection and
then i just loved them and was doing all
kinds of research on like what they do
and that's how to manifest yeah i just
like the vibes i think it's a cute thing
so i just kept buying them and now every
sunday
i go to the melrose trading post and
there is a woman who sells big crystals
shout out to nora
she knows me and every time i walk up
she's like sid she said i got a good one
i gotta go got a new one it looks good
and i said stay less
the uh yeah are you into like the
transformative properties and the
healing properties is that what you do
you look for the aesthetic like the what
they look like or are you more
interested in like what they
can do for you
yeah i'm very interested in like what
they can do for you which ones are good
for certain things i like citrine a lot
that one is good like success career
stuff like that so every time i'm going
into meetings and stuff i'll have like a
little citrine in my pocket or like
sitting next to my computer
and so i like that one a lot but also
you know i just buy them because they're
cute sometimes oh of course do you do
the cleansing rituals do you put them on
under the moon
yes yes i have my sage
my apartment however does not have a
balcony so about like once a month i
call my friend maddie who lives upstairs
and i'm like can i use your balcony i
need to stage my crystals
so i go up there i stage my crystals and
then
every full moon
i put my water out when people don't
know what that is what what is that
exactly what like sage yeah well for
staging your crystals
yeah so it's just a plant it's an herb
and burning it it smells nice and it's
just supposed to get out all the
negative energy and kind of reset your
crystals they recommend doing it every
month and there's different methods to
cleanse them i like sage or also another
one would be
setting them out in the full moon or you
can put a bowl of water outside during
the full moon and then you can cleanse
them in that water the next day oh
people do a lot of things with full moon
water they like yeah they wash their
face right there that's i was gonna ask
you have you ever drank it because i
recently learned that you can drink this
this thing and i don't know how i feel
about it yet but i'm not opposed to it
i'm not opposed but i just haven't done
it yet so maybe this month's full moon
i'll just make sure i'm extra thirsty
and just yeah you could also i mean i
feel like there's a full moon face mask
that's a possibility with some full moon
water just saying
it's like
that time
all right well you're talking about los
angeles you just recently moved here
i did i moved officially september 1st
okay 21. how has that transition been
it's been
fairly easy it's a lot easier than i
thought but i was taking very frequent
trips out here whether it's for
collaborations work opportunities
auditions stuff like that so it got to
the point where it was like i am just
sick of being on five hour flights i
think i better just you know get a place
out there and it's honestly the best
decision i've made and i'm very happy
out here for people that don't live here
what are some of the better qualities to
you of los angeles
the weather in comparison i'm from
pittsburgh pennsylvania oh yeah so i'm
used to you know when i would get up to
go to school i would have to dig my car
out of the snow yeah
at 7 a.m
to get to school uh-huh so
clearly we don't have that problem here
i love the sunshine i think it just
brightens my mood totally turns
depressing so i love the weather uh yeah
there's just so much to do out here so
much culture people are great really
accepting i just feel like there's so
many different personalities out here
and it's it's just cool to see oh yeah a
huge i mean very different than
pittsburgh my brother went to college in
pittsburgh and i've been there a few
times and i love the andy warhol museum
out there
it is very gray and overcast there a lot
a lot yeah
um
speaking of acting talk to me about this
so you've is this a new endeavor or is
this something you've been doing for a
while
um i've always been into acting even
when i was younger i would watch tv and
if i saw a scene that i liked i would
pause it and rewind it and do that until
i learned it for no reason and then i
would just be like hey mom look what i
what look what i learned and i would
just like recite like a random scene
from i don't know wizards of waverly
place or something like yeah
just any scene that like caught my eye
or like made me feel something i was
like i want to learn it and deliver it
exactly like that
so i i just kind of practiced
organically without knowing that i ever
wanted to pursue it and also i i was
doing like musical theater in high
school and stuff and i did the makeup
for that as well
nice and uh just been very into it and
so recently i um
have been acting in a few horror movies
that are coming out in 22 and so that
transition came about because of my gory
special effects makeup on you know
youtube and tick tock
so that would made a lot of sense just
to hop into the horror genre and i've
also been helping out with some of the
special effects while i'm on set which
has been cool
very cool
i'm i always like to ask people that uh
are in the world of acting if they have
any
embarrassing or unique auditioning
stories
i mean i i get a lot of scripts that are
interesting for like shelf tapes and
stuff i don't know if i have any that
stand out to me is embarrassing
that's good that's good i'm sure you'll
assume i'm sure i will if i keep this up
though yeah well how has it been being
in horror films i feel like that's such
a specific genre that you get
because i don't necessarily like scary
movies however i do appreciate that
horror films have a great sense of humor
about them they do and i've always been
interested in horror just because i am a
special effects makeup artist yeah so i
pay a little too much attention i'm like
okay when that blood squirted out what
did they use for that like how did they
make that look so like
do they use like liquid latex like how
did that happen
so i i don't know i kind of like ruin
the fun by like over analyzing them
so i've never been like that afraid of
them
and being in them is so cool it's so fun
that's great okay so we know that
they're coming out at some point this
year
yeah i have a lot coming out rolling
into halloween season so end of august
early september
right okay well we'll tease that and now
we're going to take a quick break and
when we get back guess what i have a
bunch more questions for you so we'll be
right back with more not too deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two things a big thank
you for listening to the podcast uh if
you're a regular listener if this is
your first time listening welcome and
thank you
and uh second thing if you are enjoying
yourself here in this not too deep world
we've built and you'd like to leave us a
review that would be so wonderful if you
can go to the itunes store the app store
and leave us a lovely little review
comment how are you feeling good bad
otherwise maybe just good or otherwise
would be appreciated other than that
enjoy the podcast
i went through identified all of them
and then looked up what like the you
know healing properties were of them all
and i realized that like oh when i
bought these crystals i must have been
[ __ ] stressed out because all of
these means
yeah i have 85
wow really
and do you have a cap on
when you'll stop or no
no my goal is when i have a house i want
a crystal that's taller than me and just
like
do you feel
here's my question about them because
sometimes maybe this is just in my head
i feel like when they're all together
too close it's like too much energy
going on do you ever have much energy
that i'm like i feel chaotic right now
yeah i i strategically spread mine out
like i have my black tourmaline by my
front door because it absorbs negative
energy as people are coming and going
nice i have my rose quartz by my
bathroom mirror because like self-love
i'm always yes looking at myself stuff
like that yes and obviously the citrine
in the studio
nice for career so i i spread them out
nice
um okay i want to ask about your
creative process when you're making
take like what's your
day-to-day creative process like do you
have like a system that you do do you
wake up and do it right away do you kind
of just like let inspiration find you
what do you do
so that's that's a hard thing because it
started as something that was a hobby
and i was creative when i wanted to be
creative or i was inspired to be
creative and then somewhere along the
line that turned into a career yeah so
now it's kind of like i have to force
myself to be creative but i also want to
hold on to like the enjoyment and the
passion and not feel like i'm forcing it
and make myself hate it yeah so finding
that balance was hard and i definitely
had my moment of i'm over doing it and i
would sit down in the studio and i would
cry because i didn't want to do it i was
like i don't want to do makeup
so i'm good now though
i found like the good gallon so i i
don't force myself to do insane 12-hour
makeup look every day that's good so
what happens now is i'll have maybe a
general idea or something that i see
about my day will be like oh that could
be a cool makeup look whether i'm like
you know walking outside and i see a
whole plant or like a cool like mural on
the wall or
anything like that and i'm always like
taking pictures of stuff and i just like
to be inspired by random things or even
like i'll read a quote that makes me
feel a certain emotion and then i'll be
like oh let's put that on my face
so it's very much like as far as the
emotional side it's like getting what's
in here like out yeah you know a canvas
which just happens to be my face at the
time yeah yeah yeah translating it yeah
so that's that's how it sparks or i have
a journal that i am always sketching out
like i have face charts that i like
sketch makeup looks on and
um stuff like that nice well with that
i'm curious
if you have any trend predictions so
like for this year coming up or that
we're now into 2022
any predictions in the world of makeup
is there going to be a certain
product a certain
feature of the face that's going to get
emphasized our our ears in this year
what's going on
in your
metaphorical crystal ball what do you
see for this year that's such a hard
thing to predict i mean yeah
i feel like it's changing every second
of the day it is ever changing and it's
hard to keep up with yeah so i i
trying my best to stay on top of it um a
makeup look trend that maybe we'll catch
on but i i'm starting to do
is actually focused on my crystals so i
did a series that was on zodiac signs
yeah i did a makeup look that i felt
like was inspired by like what embodies
certain zodiac signs and i did one for
every sign and now i'm gonna do every
crystal oh
i'm gonna do a makeup look that i feel
like uh embodies like the energy that
that crystal gives or the color schemes
and stuff like that so maybe other
people will be inspired to do crystal
makeup i don't know cool
i think that's awesome
um now i'm curious what do you watch do
you what are you are there people that
you watch constantly on tick tock or
youtube or wherever what shows are you
obsessed with right now like what do you
take in entertainment wise
it's hard i just i don't have that much
free time to watch things like i used to
it's kind of sad honestly but like
um
i i've watched a lot of beauty youtubers
like uh bretman rock james charles uh
glam and gore
nikki tutorials
i've watched everyone that was kind of
prior to my tick tock but
more now
shows that i've watched i mean i watched
squid game
when that was popping off great show
that's i would love to be in something
like with that plot that's so
interesting yeah i was going to ask you
too with the acting and everything
what are the goals what would you like
to do in that world
yeah so i'm working on getting out of
the horse genre okay okay i have had a
lot
of experience there now and i'm ready
for something new yeah
so uh i would love to be a lead in
something it's just like i would be in a
comedy honestly i feel like that would
be so fun or and i i feel like i'm more
into film than i am tv like okay
i don't know to get a film rather than a
series but either would be great you
gotta manifest it put it all out yeah
and as far as plot goes i would love to
be in something that's similar to like
pretty little liars
gossip girl the vampire diaries because
that is a little bit of horror not
necessarily but it's a little dark it's
a little dark and i like that yeah
something like that would be a lot of
fun very cool
[Music]
okay
now i'm gonna move on to the two
questions i ask every single guest that
is on the podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most like to
throw cold spaghetti at
oh
yeah can it be an animated character it
can be absolutely anyone or anything
that comes to mind
okay how about have you ever seen the
movie frozen
yes i have
i that's one of my favorite movies
i would throw a fistful of cold
spaghetti at prince hans yeah
i would love that i would love for it to
start as live action and turn into
animation in air mid-air yes and be
beautiful
okay
the other question i ask every single
guest is to tell us your worst pant
[ __ ] story or like a bathroom
emergency situation i know this for you
might be
triggering
disease i know i was like this might be
a triggering question um but
the
you can only use three words or three
small phrases to describe the situation
so for me
mine is college jogging front lawn
let's see there's just
an abundance of opportunities for this
one
let's see this is a fun one
colitis flare
oh
and then hospital oh
a prom in a hospital oh i mean the
memories you've come so far and it was a
great time
oh good
um okay now we have a section of the
podcast called deep and hot where i ask
you
i know so sorry i asked you a deep
question that we've prepared for you and
for your hot take on kind of like a
topic-ish that we've prepared for you
so deep question for you
is do you think there always needs to be
an end goal
no
no why i think so
i mean i i like to shed a lot of like
short-term goals but i mean if there's
no end goal but it's bringing you like
enjoyment or happiness or helping your
life in a certain way then i don't think
there ever has to be an end yeah very
true
totally i'm curious too do you have any
i know you love crystals so do you have
any other like rituals or self-care
habits that you do either on a daily
basis or you know when the time is right
yeah i do a lot of like skin care and
stuff like that i just enjoy it it feels
like my me time to kind of de-stress and
yeah i like doing it so similar to how i
enjoy like putting on the makeup and
getting all done up
i also enjoy like kind of taking it off
and putting on a face mask and just like
sitting in a bubble bath with an
eyelashes stuff like that
oh i'm also curious about your cat boots
is he's at the vet right now getting
neutered okay i thought he's dying i was
like oh my god
i just heard about our [ __ ] story
and now i'm asking about a potentially
dead cat okay because i missed him so
much i had to drop him off at 8 am this
morning and i can't pick him up until
fine he's getting neutered you said yes
oh my gosh
wow so is he a baby
he's a baby he's like five months wow
so you got him when you moved here to
los angeles i did so i had a cat back
home for
she's like two now her name is jazzy
she's a rag doll cute and i am my
parents youngest child so and
technically it was my cat but i'm like i
can't move across the country and also
take the cat yeah that's a lot i can't
do that to them
so i came out without a pet i'm like
i'll just get settled in it'll be fine
and when i walk to go get my mail i walk
past this one apartment who has a really
cute cat and i know that if i went to
get my belt like 2 p.m the sun was
perfectly shining through the window and
the cat would be sitting in this sun
patch so i'd be like oh it's two i gotta
go
and then i would just stand there and
look at this cat i was like you're a
creep why
oh that's great yeah most people are
like the hot mailman is coming at 2 p.m
so i have to go make sure i'm down there
and you're like no i got to go the sun
is hitting this cute cat in the perfect
way i have to go see this
my friends were like [ __ ]
that's so weird just get one
that's great that's so pure i love that
um okay
now here's uh the hot take kind of genre
topic that we have for you i'm curious
about you know a lot of people talk
about the social media verse reality of
everything um what's your hot take on
finding the balance of that because i do
see that on your social media you are
you know you share aspects of your
personal life but you do seem to have
like a boundary that's like healthy that
you're not over sharing absolutely every
second of your life um so i'm curious
what your thoughts are on that do you
consider that and make a conscious
effort to kind of
stay keep some things behind the curtain
yeah it is very hard balance and a lot
of people do a lot of different things
and i'm still you know kind of learning
and figuring out as i go sure uh i do
like to keep certain aspects uh to
myself and personal and offline because
then i feel like they're still mine yeah
because when i'm posting things and
sharing them it's kind of like opening
myself up to everyone's opinions or
and that i didn't necessarily ask for
but that's just kind of goes along with
being online and
being a social
influencer and so it's hard because i do
want to
share enough to kind of have like a
personal connection relationship with my
followers but also
kind of keep some things to myself so
they stay mine yeah i think that's
incredibly healthy
that's great
um i'm also curious
uh if you
what are some of the weirdest requests
or messages that you've gotten if any
i'm sure there's been plenty
i did a lot um there is a recurring need
for feet pictures that i see in my dms
all the time
i'm like why
it's uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm glad that you have that boundary
though of keeping your feet to yourself
because once they're out there you can't
get them back it's an ongoing joke with
me and my friends any time we post a
photo that our feet are in we censor
them yeah yeah even even on snapchat if
it's just like
a photo of my friend they put their feet
are in it we censor them and we say not
for free yeah
yeah that's that's the last minute
business plan is when the feet become
available when all other revenue streams
have dried up yeah just just know if you
ever see me selling feed pictures my
career is not doing well that i'm not
doing well my career is not doing well
and someone should intervene at this
point yeah please send help
um
now i'm just kind of curious like what's
coming up for you what's next what's
gonna what's the plan for this year we
know that there's some horror stuff
coming out
but anything else going on
well i am constantly doing auditions and
self tapes so definitely stay tuned for
more acting things coming out hopefully
branching out a bit from the horror
genre nice um i am working on some
products of my own oh
makeup moment i'm not gonna say too much
but she's in the works cool um i
could potentially be working on my music
this year as well ah
okay i know you mentioned that you were
a musical theater okay
i have vocal nodules right now that i
need to get surgery for so it's kind of
been on hold gotcha but uh hopefully we
can get that figured out this year cool
very very cool i'm so excited for you
thank you
um we've kind of reached the end of the
podcast but before we wrap up everything
completely we like to give a little
token of our appreciation to our guests
and that is a personalized horoscope
from us to you
that melissa will put in the chat and
when she does if you're able to read it
aloud to the class that would be great
okay
dear aquarius a water bearer of the
stars you may feel a sense of emptiness
where a romantic partner would sit
however rather than distracting oneself
from what you lacked we suggest living
up to your new year's resolution which
is crystals cash and cats the three c's
baby
that's all you need that's literally all
you need and then after i posted it i
was like i should have added candles
because i'm also a crazy candle lady are
you what's your burning in my apartment
what's your go-to scent
there's this one i don't even know where
it's from it's called the perfect
christmas and it
like
smells
perfect christmas
i i guess so so if they stop releasing
it because it gets far away from
christmas i'm gonna have to find a new
one oh no
um
sydney this has been so lovely where can
people find you online or wherever you
want them to if they don't already know
yeah so on tick tock i'm just sending
underscore art sydney dot morgan and
owen morgan is zero on snapchat and
instagram and then cindy morgan on
youtube and that's about it awesome well
thank you again this has been so great
and i cannot wait to see the horror
movies and whatever else you get into
this year
uh thank you guys so much for listening
and watching we'll see you next time on
another episode of not too deep
too
goodbye
too deep deep not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music